♪ ♪
>> Chris: WHITE HOUSE
NEGOTIATORS AND DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS MET 11
TIMES TO DISCUSS THE CORONAVIRUS
RELIEF PACKAGE BEFORE
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK HIS
EXECUTIVE ACTION YESTERDAY.
JOINING US NOW FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, TREASURY SECRETARY
STEVEN MNUCHIN.
MR. SECRETARY, WELCOME BACK TO
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY"."
>> Secretary Mnuchin:
THANK YOU, CHRIS, IT’S GOOD TO
BE WITH YOU.
>> Chris: YOU JUST HEARD
SPEAKER PELOSI’S REACTION TO THE
STEPS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK
YESTERDAY.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: FIRST OF
ALL LET ME JUST SAY IT WAS THE
PRESIDENT’S FIRST CHOICE TO GO
UP AND NEGOTIATE A FAIR DEAL, SO
MARK MEADOWS AND I NEGOTIATED
NONSTOP.
WE WENT THROUGH EVERY SINGLE
LINE ITEM WITH THEM FOR TWO
WEEKS.
IT MAY JUST GIVE YOU A SENSE OF
THE SPIRIT ON EDUCATION, THEY
WANTED 100 BILLION, WE AGREED TO
105 BILLION, THEY THEN RAISED
THEIR NUMBER TO 400 BILLION.
AS THE SPEAKER JUST SAID, THEY
WANTED MONEY FOR FOOD, WE
COMPROMISED ON FOOD, WE ACTUALLY
REACHED AN AGREEMENT ON THAT.
WE HAVE THE POSTMASTER
GENERAL OF --
>> Chris: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
MR. SECRETARY, LET ME JUST ASK
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE SHE KEPT
REFERRING TO $250,000 FOR FOOD
RELIEF, IS THAT TRUE?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: WE CAME
UP TO A VERY FAIR COMPROMISE.
WE ACTUALLY REACHED AN AGREEMENT
ON WHAT THEY WANTED WITHOUT
LONG-TERM CHANGES ON POLICY AND
WE KNOCKED THAT OFF THE LIST.
LET ME JUST TELL YOU WHAT
THEY’VE REFUSED TO NEGOTIATE ON.
AND WE SET TELL US YOU ARE ON A
COMPROMISE OR STATE AND LOCAL,
THEY SAID WE ARE AT A TRILLION
DOLLARS.
WE SAID TELL US WHERE YOU ARE ON
ENHANCED ON APPOINTMENT, WE TOLD
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WE WILL KEEP
IT AT 600 WHILE WE NEGOTIATE FOR
A WEEK OR TWO, THEY REFUSED TO
DO THAT.
THOSE TWO ISSUES, THEY REFUSED
ANY COMPROMISE ON MOSTLY EVERY
SINGLE OTHER ISSUE WE’VE RACED
TO MIKE REACHED AN AGREEMENT
THAT WOULD HAPPEN ON FRIDAY WAS
THIS A CALL US BACK, WE SAID THE
PRESIDENT, NOW YOU’VE GOT TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH EXECUTIVE
ACTION SO THAT YOU CAN HELP
AMERICAN WORKERS AND AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Chris: BUT MR. SECRETARY,
LET’S TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT’S ACTIONS THAT HE TOOK
YESTERDAY, AND WE TALKED ABOUT
THEY DID, BUT TALK ABOUT WHAT
THEY DON’T DO.
THEY DON’T PROVIDE ANOTHER $1200
DIRECT PAYMENT TO PEOPLE.
DON’T RESTORE THE PAYROLL
PROTECTION PROGRAM, WHICH HELPS
SMALL BUSINESSES.
THAT RAN OUT YESTERDAY.
HERE’S WHAT DEMOCRATS SAID
DURING THE NEGOTIATIONS.
>> THERE ARE REAL NEEDS,
AMERICAN KNOWS THEY HAVE
RELATES, THE PUBLIC IS ON OUR
SIDE.
BUT THEY SEEM NOT TO BE WILLING
TO GO IN A DIRECTION THAT WOULD
MEET THOSE NEEDS.
>> IT’S HARD WHEN YOUR VALUES
ARE SO DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF
WORKING -- BUBBLE UP FROM THE
WORKING CLASS FAMILIES INSTEAD
OF TRICKLE DOWN FROM ABOVE.
>> Chris: MR. SECRETARY, YOU
HEARD SPEAKER PELOSI SAY SHE
WOULD LIKE TO RESUME TALKS.
ARE YOU READY TO DO SO, AND
FRANKLY, GIVEN THESE DIFFERENCES
IN WHAT YOU HEARD FROM HER
TODAY, WHY SHOULD WE THINK THAT
THE NEGOTIATIONS THIS WEEK WOULD
GO ANY BETTER THAN THE FAILED
NEGOTIATIONS OF THE LAST TWO
WEEKS?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: WELL,
CHRIS, I’VE TOLD THE SPEAKER AND
SENATOR SCHUMER, ANY TIME THEY
HAVE A NEW PROPOSAL, I’M WILLING
TO LISTEN.
LET ME JUST SAY YOU’RE RIGHT, WE
AGREED WITH THE DEMOCRATS, WE
BOTH WANT TO SEND MORE CHECKS TO
THE AMERICAN WORKERS.
WE WANT TO SEND MORE PPP TO
THOSE HARDEST HIT BUSINESSES.
WE SAID LET’S PASS LEGISLATION
ON THE THINGS THAT WE AGREE ON
AND KNOCK THESE OFF ONE AT A
TIME, AND THEY’VE REFUSED TO DO
THAT UNTIL THEY GET THEIR
TRILLION DOLLARS FOR THE STATES.
I’VE ALSO SPOKE TO MANY
GOVERNORS OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS.
WE OFFERED MORE MONEY FOR THE
STATES, THEY STILL HAVE
150 BILLION FROM LAST TIME.
OUST OF THEM HAVEN’T EVEN USED
HALF THE MONEY.
IF THE GOVERNORS ARE SAYING WE
NEED MORE MONEY FOR EDUCATION,
WE NEED HELP ON THE
PRESIDENT SAYS WE WILL GIVE IT
TO YOU, BUT NOT A TRILLION
DOLLARS.
>> Chris: MR. SECRETARY, I
WANT TO REFER TO SOMETHING THAT
SPEAKER PELOSI REFERENCE, AND
THAT WAS THE COMMENT FROM
REPUBLICAN SENATOR BEN SASSE
THAT THIS GOVERNING BY EXECUTIVE
ACTION IS, HIS WORDS,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL SLOP.
WHAT MAKES YOU THINK THAT
SPENDING OVER $100 BILLION THAT
CONGRESS HAS NOT APPROPRIATED
FOR THESE SPECIFIC PURPOSES IS
LEGAL, AND WHAT HAPPENS IF
THERE’S A COURT SUIT AND ALL OF
THE ACTIONS THAT THE PRESIDENT
TOOK YESTERDAY ARE BLOCKED BY A
FEDERAL COURT?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: LET ME
JUST SAY WE’VE CLEARED WITH THE
OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL ALL
THESE ACTIONS BEFORE THEY WENT
TO THE PRESIDENT.
IF THE PRESIDENT NEW
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE WAS
ENDING.
HE SAID, LET’S CONTINUE WITH
$400.
BY THE WAY, THE 25% FROM THE
STATES, THEY CAN EITHER TAKE
THAT OUT OF THE MONEY WE’VE
ALREADY GIVEN THEM FOR THE
PRESIDENT CAN WAIVE THAT.
WE’VE BEEN TOLD BY THE STATES
THEY CAN GET THIS UP AND RUNNING
IMMEDIATELY.
AND I WOULD SAY IF THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO CHALLENGE US IN COURT
AND HOLD UP ON A PLUMBING
BENEFITS TO THOSE HARDWORKING
AMERICANS THAT ARE OUT OF A JOB
BECAUSE OF COVID, THEY’RE GOING
TO HAVE A LOT OF EXPLAINING TO
DO.
>> Chris: AS WE SAY, YOU HAVE
CUT THE FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFIT FROM $600 TO 400, 300
FROM THE FEDS.
$100 -- THIS IS A WEEK, $100
FROM STATES WHAT YOU SAY A LOT
OF THAT WOULD COME FROM FEDERAL
MONEY THEY’VE ALREADY RECEIVED.
DO YOU REALLY THINK THAT THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS -- THAT THE
MILLIONS OF FAMILIES THAT LOST
JOBS BECAUSE OF THE VIRUS DON’T
NEED THAT MONEY, THAT THEY DON’T
NEED THE EXTRA $200 A WEEK?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: CHRIS,
LET ME BE CLEAR, FIRST OF ALL ON
THE 25%, THAT’S COMING FROM
MONEY WE ALREADY GAVE THE
STATES, SO THIS IS EFFECTIVELY
100% PAID FOR BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
LET ME ALSO REMIND YOU THAT
OBAMA DURING THE FINANCIAL
CRISIS PAID A $25 POP UP, SO
THIS HAS NEVER BEEN DONE IN THE
HISTORY OF TIME.
WITH OUR $400 WAS A FAIR
COMPROMISE, BUT LET ME JUST ALSO
SAY WE OFFERED TO CONTINUE TO
PAY $600 WHILE WE NEGOTIATE IN
THE DEMOCRATS TURNED THAT DOWN.
>> Chris: BUT WAIT, SIR, THAT
WAS ONLY FOR ONE WEEK.
THAT WAS ONLY FOR ONE WEEK.
IF >> Secretary Mnuchin:
ACTUALLY WE EXTENDED IT TO TWO
WEEKS BUT THEY MADE PERFECTLY
CLEAR THEY’RE NOT GOING TO AGREE
ON A PIECEMEAL DEAL.
THEY WANT TO HOLD UP THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC FROM GETTING THE
MONEY THEY NEED UNTIL THEY GET
EVERYTHING THEY WANT, WHICH IS
JUST A BAD OUTCOME.
>> Chris: THAT’S TALK ABOUT
ANOTHER ISSUE, AND THAT IS THE
SUSPENSION OF PAYROLL TAXES,
WHICH EVEN A NUMBER OF
REPUBLICAN SENATORS OPPOSED.
THERE ARE TWO ISSUES THERE SEEM
TO BE HERE.
FIRST OF ALL, SUSPENDING PAYROLL
TAXES DOESN’T HELP THE MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT OF JOBS
AND DON’T HAVE TO PAY PAYROLL
TAXES, SO THEY DON’T GET A
BENEFIT THERE AND IT’S ALSO NOT
A PAYROLL TAX CUT, IT’S A
PAYROLL TAX SUSPENSION.
ISN’T THERE A DANGER THAT A LOT
OF BUSINESSES WON’T PASS THE
SAVINGS THROUGH TO WORKERS
BECAUSE THEY’RE GOING TO HOLD
ONTO THE MONEY INASMUCH AS AT
SOME POINT, ACCORDING TO THIS
EXECUTIVE ACTION BY THE END OF
THE YEAR OF THOSE PAYROLL TAXES
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE PAID
ANYWAY?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: THE
PRESIDENT WANTED TO DO A PAYROLL
TAX CUT.
WE COULD DO THE PAYROLL TAX
DEFERRAL.
HE’S GOING TO GO TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND TELL THEM THAT WHEN
HE’S REELECTED HE WILL PUSH
THROUGH LEGISLATION TO FORGIVE
THAT, SO IN ESSENCE IT WILL TURN
INTO A PAYROLL TAX CUT.
BUT LET ME JUST ALSO SAY FOR THE
HARDWORKING PEOPLE THAT DON’T
HAVE JOBS, THAT’S WHAT WE’D
EXTENDED THE $400.
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING IS LET’S
PASS LEGISLATION ON 70 OR 80% OF
THE THINGS THAT WE AGREE ON SO
WE CAN GET MONEY IMMEDIATELY TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
SCHOOLS NEED TO REOPEN SAFELY.
I’VE SPOKEN TO MANY OF THE
GOVERNORS BOTH DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS.
THEY NEED THIS MONEY, WE HAVE
MORE THAN ENOUGH MONEY TO GIVE
IT TO THEM.
AND THE SPEAKER IS HOLDING THAT
UP.
>> Chris: I WANT TO PICK UP ON
WHAT YOU JUST SAID, THAT IF THE
PRESIDENT IS REELECTED, HE WOULD
LIKE TO CUT THE PAYROLL TAX.
THE PAYROLL TAX IS WHAT FINANCES
SOCIAL SECURITY.
MEDICARE.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW SAYING IF
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS REELECTED, IS
GOING TO GOT THOSE PROGRAMS
BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO GOT THE
TAX THAT PAYS FOR THEM.
>> Secretary Mnuchin: THAT’S
NOT THE CASE.
THERE WOULD BE AN AUTOMATIC
CONTRIBUTION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO THOSE TRUST FUNDS.
THE PRESIDENT IN NO WAY WANTS TO
HARM THOSE TRUST FUNDS.
SO THEY WOULD BE REIMBURSED JUST
OF THE ALWAYS BEEN IN THE PAST
WHEN WE’VE DONE THESE TYPES OF
THINGS.
>> Chris: SO YOU’RE SAYING
THAT THERE WOULD BE NO PAYROLL
TAX CUT, THERE WOULD BE AN
INCOME TAX --, WHAT, INCREASE?
WE ARE ALREADY RUNNING HUGE
DEFICITS, SO HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO PAY FOR FROM THE GENERAL FUND
MXP TO THERE’S A PAYROLL TAX CUT
WHICH IS LIKE ANY OTHER TAX CUT
TO HARDWORKING AMERICANS AND YOU
JUST HAVE A TRANSFER FROM THE
GENERAL FUND.
SO DURING FISCAL TIMES, WE ARE
FOCUSED ON TAX CUTS, REGULATORY
RELIEF, DIRECT PAYMENTS TO
AMERICANS.
WE WILL DEAL WITH THE BUDGET
DEFICIT WHEN WE GET THE ECONOMY
BACK TO WHERE IT WAS BEFORE.
RIGHT NOW WHERE FOCUSED ON
DELIVERING VERY NEEDED RELIEF TO
AMERICAN FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED DURING THIS TERRIBLE
COVID ECONOMIC ISSUE.
>> Chris: JUST TO BE CLEAR
HERE THOUGH, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING THE RESULT OF A PAYROLL
TAX CUT AS IT WOULD MEAN A CUT
IN BENEFITS FOR SOCIAL SECURITY
AND MEDICARE, TO WHICH YOU
SAY --
>> Secretary Mnuchin: THAT’S
JUST FACTUALLY INACCURATE.
THERE WOULD BE NO REDUCTION TO
THOSE BENEFITS AND THE PRESIDENT
HAS MADE THAT VERY CLEAR.
BUT THE ISSUE HERE IS LET’S PASS
LEGISLATION ON THINGS THAT WE
AGREE ON.
LET’S NOT HOLD UP MONEY
EDUCATION FOR KIDS GETTING BACK
TO SCHOOL SAFELY.
LET’S NOT HOLD UP MONEY TO STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHERE THEY
NEEDED.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO COME OFF
OF A RIDICULOUS TRILLION DOLLAR
NUMBER TWO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BAIL OUT SOME OF
THE STATES THAT WERE POORLY
MANAGED.
>> Chris: LET ME JUST ASK
BRIEFLY ON THAT, THEY ARE
TALKING 900 BILLION, NOT QUITE A
TRILLION, BUT 900 BILLION,
YOU’RE TALKING 150 BILLION.
IS THERE A PLACE IN BETWEEN
THERE FOR AID TO STATES AND
CITIES?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: THEY ARE
ACTUALLY ASKING FOR 915, PLUS
THE REVERSAL, WHICH GET TO OVER
2 TRILLION, ON US, WE GAVE 150
IN THE LAST BILL, WE WILL GIVE
ANOTHER 150 MORE.
WE WILL DEAL WITH ISSUES IN
JANUARY, THIS WILL BE THE FIFTH
BILL, WE DON’T HAVE TO GET
EVERYTHING DONE AT ONCE.
WE SHOULD DO IS GET THINGS DONE
FOR THE AMERICAN PUBLIC NOW,
COME BACK FOR ANOTHER BILL
AFTERWARDS.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, I’VE GOT
ABOUT A MINUTE LEFT AND THAT GOT
A BIG QUESTION AND I’M GOING TO
COUNT ON YOU TO GIVE ME A QUICK
ANSWER.
LET’S TURN TO THE ECONOMY AND
THE LATEST JOBS NUMBERS.
IT’S PUT UP ON THE SCREEN.
IN MAY, WE ADDED 2.8 MILLION
JOBS.
WE ADDED 4.8 MILLION IN JUNE,
BUT IN JULY, ONLY 1.8 MILLION.
THAT’S STILL -- SO CLEARLY THE
JOB CREATION IS SLOWING DOWN AND
THAT’S STILL LESS THAN HALF OF
THE JOBS THAT WERE LOST IN MARCH
AND APRIL.
A SPIKE IN THE VIRUS AND PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY ARE EVEN SLOWING
DOWN OR EVEN STOPPING.
ISN’T THE VITALITY OF THIS
RECOVERY BEING THREATENED.
ISN’T THE V-SHAPED TURNING INTO
SOME OTHER LETTER OF THE
ALPHABET?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: WE
LITERALLY SHUTDOWN THE U.S.
ECONOMY, WE ARE BRINGING BACK
JOBS.
WE BROUGHT BACK A LOT.
THE PRESIDENT’S WORK IS NOT DONE
UNTIL WE GET ALL THE JOBS BACK
AND THAT’S WHAT HE WANTS TO
CONTINUE TO SEND MONEY TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, SO THIS ECONOMY
COMES BACK IN EVER BUT HE GETS
THEIR JOBS BACK.
>> Chris: MR. SECRETARY,